[Música]
muy buenas noches a todos ahora quiero
que me vean muy bien ok
así como di y piensen
entonces es una niña dando una charla te
normal sí sí pero qué pasa si les digo
que aproximadamente hace como cinco años
era una persona totalmente diferente
una persona que era literalmente un
desastre
pero decidí cambiar
y eso me hizo cuestionar
es sorprendente ver que nadie se haya
dado cuenta impresionante ver como las
personas que me ven a diario todas las
personas en mi salón mis amigos
parientes casi casi
se me quedaron viendo con preguntas y
asombro es enseño original
en serio quieres disléxica
yo les respondí
claro que soy totalmente y esta es la
realidad que vivo todos los días
pero no siempre es fácil para nada
así que quiero empezar con una pregunta
cuántos de ustedes conocen personas
creativas e intuitivas y visuales por
favor levanten la mano
varios una gran cantidad pues sí que
pasa se les digo que estas son
características principales de
disléxicos buenas noches mi nombre es
rígida nuño y les vengo a hablar sobre
la idea errónea de la dislexia
al principio me preguntaba pues por qué
yo tenía que esforzarme el triple que
las personas de mi edad para encontrarme
en el promedio
esas preguntas se me repetía
constantemente en la cabeza y no
encontraba ninguna solución
ni una respuesta
así que los voy a leer la mente me
interesa mucho saber qué es lo que la
mayoría piensa que es la dislexia
así que supongo que lo primero crezca en
la cabeza es confunden letras así de
fácil o que las de la inteligencia los
ha definido que es una incapacidad que
no te permite vivir como una persona
normal y te etiqueta como diferente
sorprendente no los que pasen les digo
que en algún punto posiblemente esté lo
correcto pero no en todo
les quiero contar un poco de mi
experiencia personal cuando era pequeña
en 3º de primaria yo batallaba un chorro
con la escritura al grado en el que mis
padres meza en repetir cada palabra que
me equivocara diez veces para ver si así
podía de alguna forma mejorar
pero el problema era que desconocíamos
la razón principal de mi problema que me
hacía tipo
así que les quiero decir la verdad sobre
la dislexia
quiero que la conozcan y aprendan con
claridad quiero que se queden con esto
principalmente que la dislexia no es una
incapacidad y para nada define tu
inteligencia
al contrario es una capacidad que
algunas personas son capas son las
personas tienen la habilidad de tenerla
porque la dislexia no se escoge
la dislexia
puede ser estar en situaciones
relacionadas con la escritura
matemáticas y escritura
pero qué pasa si podemos aprender a
desarrollarla desarrollarla al grado que
también veamos el lado positivo de ella
dando una vuelta de 180 grados
totalmente diferente
quiero que vean estas cualidades
principales de los disléxicos
son capaces de leer imágenes
son extremadamente curiosos
y muchas otras que nos hacen
aprender en otras en otros sentidos
pero la noche no nos define como somos
quiero que vean también esto muy
importante
todos estos son famosos que sospecharon
y algunos de estamos definitivamente que
tuvieron dislexia empecemos con autores
einstein un famoso todo el mundo lo
conoce los que pasa si le decimos
que al ser pequeño al cuadrado era
pequeño la mayoría de las personas le
decía que no era suficientemente
inteligente en la escuela de decían que
no era apto que era muy malo en las
matemáticas
y conocemos la realidad de un increíble
científico que aún sigue siendo
extremadamente admirable estos días
veamos el caso de thomas alva edison
él fue expulsado de la escuela cuando
era joven porque no era capaz de seguir
a su salón y eso fue mucho antes después
que el resto llorará el desarrollara
el increíble invento del foco y walt
disney algo rechazado de 25 empresas que
le dijeron que no era suficientemente
creativo la mayoría bueno lo que podemos
ver todos ellos famosos que es que se
estrellaron contra el fracaso pero no
dejaron que eso los detuviera no dejaron
que eso los definiera como
dato curioso de la dislexia como
mencioné antes la dislexia no puedes
la directa es algo que adquieres sí o sí
ya que se pasa otros códigos genéticos y
desde que nacemos podemos saber si somos
disléxicos o no
también quiero que observen con claridad
esta imagen vean bien pueden leer lo que
dice aquí
pues la mayoría podría sí pero qué pasa
si les digo que también los disléxicos
se les facilita este tipo de cosas
puedes leer el texto a la primera
regresando a mi historia después de
descubrir que nada pero nada lo que
hacía funcionaba después de constantes
repeticiones e ir a lugares en donde me
reforzará la matemática la escritura
todo y al ver que nada llegara a
funcionar fuimos a que me hicieran los
estudios ahí fue cuando descubrimos que
mi monstruo tenía nombre y era la
dislexia
y ahí fue cuando mis padres
interfirieron y estoy bien agradecida
por ellos porque si no fuera por ellos
no sé si estaría aquí hablando en frente
de ustedes
lo que hizo mi mamá principalmente fue
que ella tomó un curso para aprender que
era la dislexia ella lo hizo para
comprender mi situación y ver cómo podía
ayudarme a mí
y qué pasa si les digo que el día de hoy
amo la lectura todas las noches antes de
dormir me echo como diez páginas también
he ido a dos competencias de matemáticas
y la verdad que me ha ido muy bien y
esta es mi segunda charla test
sorprendente no pero claro fue un
proceso complejo y duro pero no deje que
eso me detuviera
entremos un poco en estadística
vean que 1 de cada 10 personas se
sospecha que es disléxico
pues podría ser el principio máximo que
han de creer que hay un pequeño
fragmento de la población es disléxico
pues somos como 80 personas aquí ustedes
saquen las cuentas
básicamente así es como los disléxicos
son pero no quería que ustedes me vieran
a mí como una dislexia por eso es que lo
oculté por tanto tiempo quería que me
conocieran por quien en verdad era o por
mis otras cualidades también por mi
increíble sentido del humor por mi gran
carácter
por otras cualidades que no me sientan
diferente
pero mi secreto hoy salió a la luz
y no puedo hacer nada para regresar en
el tiempo y detenerlo pero lo que sí
puede hacer es pararme aquí y decirles
no tengan miedo
la aceptación es el primer paso para
amarse a sí mismos y para amar a los
demás
hay que ser conscientes que la mejor
forma
si estás hecho no tengo de otra y
existen dos opciones una lo que pude
haber hecho también es enterrar mente no
yo no puedo esto me define esto me hace
tan diferente que no puedo progresar o
no tomar la mentalidad que hice y fue
bueno esto es parte de mi realidad
entonces qué voy a hacer al respecto
tomar acción seguir adelante no dejar
que nada me detenga y ahora el grado en
el que la mayoría ustedes desconocía mi
realidad que yo era disléxico
hoy quiero invitarlos a todos ustedes a
que también vivan con valentía sin temor
al rechazo y aprendan a amarse a sí
mismos
como dice mi frase aquí juntos
descubriremos de lo que somos capaces
gracias
[Aplausos]